hallöchen meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge
monster legions ihr seht hier schon
meine wundervolle monstrum kurbelte was
ist das für ein monster das sieht aus
wie sonnen keine ahnung dass also den
habe ich mir halt geholt den kleinen
rabauken wert wer hinter dem ebenso ein
bisschen damit der bachelor ich auch
wenn sich gerade oder ich mach mal hier
damit war hier amazon jetzt auch egal
wir haben eine neue fertigkeiten rüstig
den man noch ein bisschen weiter auf das
ist immer noch viel zu laut gerade
regnet stark
ich werde mich heute so ein bisschen
darauf konzentrieren dass ich neue
fertigkeit ein verbündeter neue
fertigkeit erlernen mach mal im
gegensatz zu 123 kompaktbaureihe ich
möchte mich heute ein bisschen und das
meinen noch viele dass ich mal mehr
kämpfen soll und nicht so viel schneiden
soll weil bei so einem spiel meinte
viele sei es nicht ganz so geil wenn man
viel schneidet ich werde dann quasi
jetzt einfach so einmalig spiel gegen la
brass und gegen das die teile sehen echt
genauso auf wie oft pokémon die dinge
das ist ja richtig cool aber ich
verstehe nicht wieso reden kratzer also
eine pflanzen attacke nicht effektiv ist
gegen gegen wasser weil bei pokémon war
es vor beispielsweise immer so also das
spiel ist natürlich nicht pokémon aber
es ist schon es hat schon dinge die dort
parallelen aufweisen zum beispiel um ein
team besteht aus drei monster und ich
kämpfe gegen zwei monster bist du ein
bisschen unfair eigentlich oder wollte
einfach mal schauen was es so für
spezielle events gibt habe ich ja
gelesen haben auch viele zugeschrieben
und ich wollte einfach ein bisschen mehr
kämpfen also vielleicht auch ein
bisschen online und so vielleicht trifft
ja irgendwie den kölner außen videos
oder so aber das denke ich eher weniger
das ja immens viele leute spielen
ich hab ich mal neuer versucht haben
feier kommen bekommen hat das hat sich
richtig richtig richtig böse an feier
kommen und jetzt hole ich mir natürlich
noch ein
und jetzt freunde wenn ich jetzt noch
ein ei kriege dann restlicher völlig aus
noch einmal dass wir gold ich habe noch
ein ei bekommen freunde wie krank ist
das denn
ohne spaß wenn ich jetzt noch mal
bekomme das wäre das wäre unnormal dann
habe ich ja das spiel näher kommt jetzt
aber wie krank war das denn bitte gerade
eben so ist man monster eigentlich da
auf der 10
das gar nicht was mit dem los ist so
freunde ich kämpfe jetzt aber mal mit
einem anderen team
ich werde jetzt einfach mal die 13 grad
am kämpfen ich nehme mal den atem mit
rein asmussen monster abgewartet dann
mach ich mal der giebel ist eigentlich
ganz geil demi moore brauche ich glaube
ich nicht dann nämlich mal atom mit und
den ruderer nämlich auch mal mit dann
packt den basti wer einfach mal weg und
dann kommt der route auch mit rein und
dann schaue ich jetzt mal wie das ganze
jetzt der ruderer schon richten aber die
nehme ich natürlich locker mit denen auf
ich mal feuer auf ihn hier drauf
alter.de schon kann das ein kleiner
panda dem einfach richtig zu fuchteln
kann endlich kann ich mein team
dementsprechend ja mal anpassen also ich
hätte jetzt am besten wasser pokémon
mitgenommen ich wüsste dass dazu zwei
feuer tiger sind aber so benny natürlich
nicht der erste store feuer funke und
jetzt noch sprung schlag mir das ist
nicht so effektiv in dem mal panda
schlag auf dem dorf dann ist er schon
mal tot und dann schauen wir jetzt noch
mal schwere kirche in dem anschlag hat
sich much much much much much
schlecker an und dann nehme ich hier
nochmal schafe clown auf diesen löwen
drauf und dann müsste er auch schon tot
sein unter dem namen entstehen dritten
welt drehe das glücksrad
ich will unbedingt dieses bei das sieht
richtig geil aus schon wieder drei alter
mandaten aber ich bekomme ich glaub ich
hab sogar schon von werken egal muss man
schauen kann daten sonst sonst nicht
sehr gut
deswegen macht irgendwie zum schluss die
monster dabei die sind böse kalt ihnen
möchten die könnten bösen den arsch
treten der freunde ich habe jetzt einen
butler geholt der wird nur noch nicht
putzen der typ in diesem traurig ihr
wolltet ihr spiel konzentrieren und zwar
werde ich jetzt erstmal diese scheiße
hier entfernen ich hoffe ich habe genug
leute das machen könne erwarte ich kauf
mir mal glaube ich noch sondern so einen
kleinen arbeiter hasen ruhen änderungen
werde ich dann wahrscheinlich in der
vierten folge machen nächstes mal bei
diesen war schon krass teuer aber ich
muss mindestens stufe 28 dafür seien
dann werde ich gemeint erhaltet das
spiel so ähnlich sei wie dragon city und
poldi nach mache sei blablabla freunde
ihr müsst mal überlegen
das entfernte zwei büsche ziele resale
auch guck mal wie süß der insel soll
noch eine insel kaufen
komme ich ich ich will mir das jetzt
einfach mal ich habe mir jetzt eine
insel gegönnt alter wie geil ich weiß
nicht wofür ich die brauche weil mein
laden noch nicht so
groß ist aber was ist denn das auch das
ist diese runde die stehen erst am
anfang viele meinten dass es so ist wie
dragon city allerdings ist dragon steht
die von den gleichen leuten deswegen
kann das sehr schlechte nachmache sein
wenn es von den gleichen leuten ist an
ihr versteht was ich meine die kämpfe
jetzt übrigens mal online und zwar mit
den gleichen leuten die haben eigentlich
ganz gut gefallen ich glaube ich nehme
den hier dann 22 15 damit rein einfach
mal um zu schauen wie die sich jetzt an
online machen einfach viele meinen ja du
musst hier mehr kämpfen und dann kann
ich vielleicht doch besser kämpfen und
der luca rio gegen ios user denen kämpfe
ich mal eben und ich mache panda schlag
auf die den vorfall auf die noch mal
drüber nicht tot und dann habe ich ja
hier noch den brennenden bank optimal
dieses dieses monster jahren
siehst du das das ist ein grimmiges
einhorn das von krems nach wochen auf
denen gehe ich mit donkey kong drauf
junge tom connor 257 gemacht einfach
etwas auch schon mal einem video vor
zwei jahren dabei oder seine freunde
wisst ihr noch das video da könnt ihr
gesehen geht so freunde ich habe ein
anrecht salz bekommen ich weiß nicht was
mir results bringt so freunde dann
suchen wir uns mal direkt noch einen
anderen gegner und zwar den film alter
deren riesiges monster digger geil
meinte gerade dort kong regelt deswegen
werden wir auf jeden fall mit donkey
kong auf den typen da vorne draufgehen
altea der [ __ ] einfach alle von mir
borja mahnfeuer fall direkt erstmal auf
ihnen hier drauf der schon auf 43 er das
schafft trotzdem locker flockig den eben
dass ich finde dass so ein bisschen
traurig immer wenn ich zu der andere typ
her und ich wusste einfach der andere
besser als ich aber ich verliere ist
sodann gehe ich mal jetzt hier noch auf
den unteren drei
auf und dann werde ich jetzt noch den
wärme schlag auf denen da drauf machen
und jetzt können wir eigentlich mal eben
schauen was das denn das sondertag ich
das tier werden wie das abgestürzt oder
so und finde ich sie richtig fertig aus
wenn jetzt kann so aufgefallen
übrigens wickelte mal schauen dass ich
dieses salz verwende ich habe ja hier
ein recht salz dann mache ich mal rief
sagte lemiss intensiver hatten habe ich
mich selbst so krass heruntergeregelt
ich mal vorfeld auf denen drauf eltern
plan online.com stola pfeil auf diesen
komischen typen hinten drauf
durch irgendeine auszeichnung für mich
die nehmen kann und unsere
geschwindigkeit stufe eins ich werde
jetzt gleich einfach mal diese
geschwindigkeit anwenden aber vorher
machen wir noch mal eben einen anderen
kampf ich werde zu einer anderen leute
hier mitnehmen nicht war auf jeden fall
einen 15 und wir nehmen natürlich donkey
kong mit weil der erreger da ich
demnächst erhält zu weitere
angriffspunkte ach so ich kann immer
noch eine bestimmte anzahl an greifen
aber ich glaube ich habe jetzt mal eben
gegen frank schira case und die hat ein
cooles bild mit dem ehrmann oder so
keine ahnung herzlichen glückwunsch fall
zu einer ehe bist es freut mich sehr
aber trotzdem werde ich dich deswegen
jetzt nicht anders dar an dem in dem
spiel hier live
die nimmt mich dran was ich mache jetzt
mal eben diese peitsche hier noch auf
dem panda darauf dass der panda jetzt
nämlich erstmal schon mal tot
und yeah
doch erst noch nicht sogar ich dachte
oder sie froh jetzt kommt feuer nebel
auf ihn hier drauf dann sich um damit
schon mal die hälfte ab jetzt kommt er
hier und macht dann eine abklingzeit ist
es scheiße oder gehen jetzt auf diesen
typ mir noch mal drauf mit dem tollen
feuerball
das heißt der typ hat jetzt nur noch ein
pokemon der eigentliche ist pokémon
steht eigentlich nur für pocket monsters
das heißt es ist gar nicht schlimm wenn
ich sage dass das pokémon sind weil es
uns ja pocket monsters als was meine
geil meinte gerade gut geschlussfolgert
sherlock danke ja freunde da ist der
sieg ich frag mich ich habe bisher erst
ein kampf in dem ganzen spiel verloren
ich bin richtig gute freunde da ich
jetzt glaube ich keine ansatzpunkte mehr
habe ich weiß nicht genau wo ich meine
angriffspunkte sehe ich meine nehme mich
da das ist dieses x0 was ich da habe da
ich die nicht mehr habe übrigens ich hab
ne frage ich bin hier in dieser karte
und ich verstehe nicht wieso man monster
dar auf der 10 ist aber ich auf der 9
das ist ein bisschen verwirrend der das
war wirklich sondern bei pokémon blu-ray
doch immer der der so einfach jemand mal
weg geflogen ist so ein scheiß gemacht
hat er ja nie freunde da vorne wird
nochmal ein dings abgebaut was wollt
geschafft habe ich hab mir die insel
gekauft
ich hab' ich kann eben meine eier
abholen hier setzt sich irgendwie falsch
und mit erfüllen ich habe mal ganz kurz
im lager habe ich noch co.com obwohl ich
mir mal einfach das mache ich jetzt mal
dann hole ich mir noch eben schnell
lebensraum für wasser monster das ist
dann ganz nice eigentlich der lebensraum
des wassers ich setze mir einfach da
oben jetzt hin
ja komm mach jetzt fertig stellen hier
dann habe ich da oben den lebensraum des
wassers und dort wird dann mein como cut
sein
guck mal komik hat es richtig geil du
hast einen wasser und natur lebensraum
arbeit was sollte da möchten schnell
fertig alter leute guckt euch mal bitte
an wie viele monsters einfach gibt er
letztlich einfach außenminister crepes
oder so aber das ist ja richtig krank
guckt euch das mal an hier wie viele das
sind und das sind nur die wasser monster
alter die entwickler haben wir echt eine
heidenarbeit geleistet das ist ja
richtig nice so ich werde mich in den
komiker platz
denn hier rein das ist kommt hallo ich
bin was wie geil alter das wird ja sehr
sehr nahe
bock hat da freue ich mich richtig drauf
mit dem zu kämpfen bevor niemals noch
eben schnell dass der kommunikation ein
bisschen vom level hoch kommt und danach
muss ich auch schon wieder nach
bielefeld fahren war nicht weggesperrt
und nachahmen will das wochen ändern
soll deswegen hallo was manche
maximalstufe dem wasser pokémon massa
monster können momentan mit maximalstufe
10 aufsteigen errichtet den wasser
tempel auch dass man auch noch eben
schnell man ich möchte dieses spiel
unbedingt so richtig viel länger spielen
da haben jetzt auch schon im wasser
tempel den stelle ich jetzt eben schnell
fertig damit dem chrono cat der komik
der komiker jim crockett keine ahnung
damit ich dem auf jeden fall noch ein
bisschen aufleveln kann hier los sei
nacht da muss ich noch den master
template schnell die machen nein ich
habe nicht genug gold man freunde ja
egal wir warten jetzt einfach mal ab bis
ich mehr gold habe und dann habe ich
diese form ein bisschen mehr gekämpft
auch nicht ganz so viel gearbeitet ich
hab schon ein bisschen arbeitet aber
nicht so viel und dann sehen wir uns in
den nächsten video wieder am samstag
wenn es euch gefallen da würde ich mich
über eine bewertung freuen und links zu
dem spiel es in der beschreibung könnt
ihr auf jeden fall mal drauf klicken und
wenn ihr dasselbe halt spielen wollt und
sind meine ganzen sozialen netzwerk in
der beschreibung wir sehen uns im
nächsten video wieder chips alles
gelogen